the dolphins last year oh boy three
quarterbacks taken in the top six and
they got the one that so far so far
doesn't hold up as well in comparison to
the other two
do you think
that i i think they
barring a deshaun watson trade right
they're keeping two uh the question is
is it tua and only tua or is it tua with
some sort of veteran relief pitcher like
he had last year with ryan fitzpatrick i
think you have to have that i mean you
have to uh just you know again
i don't want to make a final
determination on two of but you said it
right it didn't speak to us to go
oh wow this is special what we're seeing
you know i i i'll say this concrete
right now
he he's not going to be joe burrow or
justin herbert ever it's not going to
happen it's not he's not that type of
talent they have special traits justin
herbert is a superstar a superstar like
a josh allen patrick mahomes type of
stuff that that's the type of throws he
makes so
yes i would think they got to have you
know some sort of backup and you know
the desean watson thing i think is very
real certainly uh still if that does
become available in an option and
houston starts you know finally
answering phone calls and all of that
but the dolphins team as a whole
you know is is they've done a really
good job in a short time they've turned
it around in a lot of areas where you
look at it and you go i like it they're
not bad there's not one area i look at
to go holy cow it's crappy they can
improve their offensive line but they
got some young guys who are also they
drafted in last year's draft who are
going to get better you know the first
and second round picks they got
offensive linemen um they need a wide
receiver to help out tua you know if you
want to make that investment you know
they need to surround him with some
talent and of course you know devonte
parker's always kind of got the injury
bug down there and had to deal with that
too so uh the support around him can
certainly improve to help to it out but
yeah they're gonna have to have somebody
whether that's a tie rod taylor you know
again an andy dalton fitzpatrick if he's
back i would think fitzpatrick would
want to favor that and be back because
he's probably seen two and go he's not
really he's not a better thrower than me
he's not better than me so i want to
come back here because i think i'll get
a chance again to play
remember three weeks ago we talked to
two and i asked him point blank do you
want ryan fitzpatrick to return and he
didn't answer the question he danced
around and he never said yes or no about
whether or not he wants fitzpatrick back
look which is the no quarterback what
quarterback wants to be the starting
pitcher and have
some other guy
right who's going to be periodically
called upon to come in and save your
bacon the mere fact that you would even
suggest that they need a guy like that
whether it's fitzpatrick tyrod taylor or
someone else the mere fact that that's
even on the radar screen tells me yeah
hey you tried and he's not the guy maybe
give him one more year to see if he's
the guy but at some point you got to
find out whether he's the guy not the
guy who's there until you you bench him
for the other guy either he's the guy or
he's not because in this day and age in
the nfl it is not sustainable to have a
quarterback who isn't good enough to
finish every game and it hurts me to say
it we love touah yeah it's a big two of
fans but you either have it or you don't
and if you don't have it to the point
where they entrust you to be the
quarterback wired a wire weekend and
weak out then that's not the answer
that's not the guy that the dolphins
need we heard torment them it's going to
haunt them they didn't take justin
herbert and dolphins fans get mad when i
say it i understand you don't you don't
want to deal with it
it's it's not a pleasant thought that
you had justin herbert right there in
the palm of your hand and you could have
had him well and you didn't you were
right that you were right during the
year i mean that's what happens when
owners make picks that's that's what
happens i don't know again
you know and and and the owner got you
know oh alabama quarterback he's winning
look at all these stats and all of that
and they got infatuated with just that
aspect listen if we went by that every
quarterback in alabama for the last 12
years should have been the first pick of
the draft like that
there's no they win their stats are
awesome first pick of the draft you know
but the hype around two was so big that
yeah they they kind of fell into the
trap there
mike i i there's people i trust in
league circles that still don't think
it's out of the realm of possibilities
that they draft a quarterback again too
i i've heard just from enough people
that i trust to think that that's still
on their radar i doubt it but i do think
it's been a topic of conversation down
there nonetheless and um yeah we'll
we'll see where it goes tua is awesome
but like you know like they say in the
godfather it's it's it's he's an awesome
person this is not personal this is just
business we're talking about here we're
talking about on the football field he
brings all the intangibles i didn't know
which way you were going to go though
when you went to the godfather i thought
you're going to say tuatanga viloa
sleeps with the fishes i wasn't quite
sure he's not luca
he's not with the fishes yet
but but you know you owe it to yourself
holding that third overall pick that you
kind of lucked into with the laramie
tunzel trade nobody expected the texans
to be that
whoa last year so here you are
hey all right trevor lawrence zach
wilson likely the first two off the
board what are we going to do with the
third pick let's evaluate all the
quarterbacks hey
maybe maybe they maybe they decide to
make the jets and offer they can't
refuse to to stick with the godfather
theme and flip-flop and get zach wilson
but i think you owe it to yourself to be
objective
to not compound your mistakes by
refusing to admit your past mistake good
luck getting stephen ross to do that if
tonga viloa was a ross prerogative pick
and uh uh you know maybe you do find
somebody better it's better to do it now
than to give it a year if you know in
your heart that it's just not going to
be there it's just not going to work you
know i think we got so caught up in
tuatanga viloa's health that maybe some
of these teams didn't take that broader
step back and ask themselves are the
tools really there if he is healthy to
be the kind of guy that's going to
thrive at a high level in the nfl i
think that's fair and listen
as an evaluator i've fallen into the
trap too before but i've tried to learn
through my years being out of the nfl to
not fall into those traps and see it for
what it is oh wait there's a guy wide
open
okay all right well yeah that was a nice
throw but i'm not gonna sit here and go
oh my gosh
whoa like he hit the wide open guy
that's gonna be a top 12 pick in the
draft and he didn't have to read a
defense and the pocket was perfect and
all that you you heard in my case last
year with this conversation there was
very little
nfl caliber throws in my opinion and
what i mean by that is
you know pocket collapsing
not big windows
not not a lot of separation for a guy to
be open and he got it in there you know
and with justin herbert and like guys
like joe burrow yeah joe burrow was in
lsu and certainly had a lot of guys wide
open but man he had so many plays where
it was like one two nobody's open let me
flip to the third side oh the third
guy's open by three inches i'll throw it
in there and boom and it looks great we
don't think anything of it but it's like
oh my gosh that's an unbelievable play
and that's the same thing with justin
herbert there was so many plays he
delivered where i go
nobody's open there's nothing and he's
throwing a perfect missile down the
field and it's a 40-yard gain and then
even on some of the incompletions where
people were on him were oh you know it
throws too many incompletions well
where is he supposed to throw it
everybody's covered and then he'd throw
a ball on a safe spot where maybe his
guy could get it or no one could get it
but it's an incompletion and it's a
negative stat so people just ride with
that and that's where you can't fall
into that trap as an evaluator as a
quarterback
i still don't think the average fan
fully appreciates how difficult it is
to walk up to the line of scrimmage you
lived it you've been there you walk up
to the line of scrimmage you have to
figure out first of all are all your
guys in the right place right that's job
number one are are any of my guys
screwed up am i screwed up am i lining
up under the guard or the center right
and then you gotta figure out what the
defense is trying to do before the snap
where is everybody where are they going
to be are they trying to fool me what
look are they giving me what's it going
to become who's the mic all the other
stuff you have to process and hope that
your offensive line is processing it in
sync with you and then you get the ball
in your hands
and all hell breaks loose right and
you're trying to figure out which of
your targets is open as you cycle
through them while you're taking the
leap of faith that your blockers are
going to keep
miles garrett yeah in company in full
armor from killing you yeah and and then
you've got to deliver an accurate pass
to the one guy who's maybe open by that
much
it's just it's unbelievable that anyone
can do it at a high level uh i i mean
again i was nothing special you know i
had a chance to be good and all that
type of stuff but even i would sit there
some days after a game and maybe played
well and go back and go man i don't know
how i made that play you know i don't
know i don't know how i did it you know
when you just think back about it but
but it's it's about playing getting used
to the game and of course when we talk
about guys like burrow and herbert and
the top young quarterbacks they're
special and to like something you always
say the game you know they have the
ability to be comfortable no matter what
and slow the game down you know and
really not see snapshots but now they're
seeing a slow-motion motion picture or
something like that and it's just in
harmony that way and then to me you know
that's what burrow and herbert were very
special at they were never you know
flustered you know tuba of course not a
lot of big time throws was jumping in
the pocket at times all that and as we
saw they had to manage him
you know greatly they really did and
when we saw when ryan fitzpatrick would
come in he'd be throwing the balls all
over the field it was the same place but
aggressive frame of mind you know just
the the the ability to anticipate and
make those throws that's something that
tua hadn't didn't have to do much at
alabama uh so we'll see where he goes
i'm not giving up on him certainly but
but i do feel confident to say that he's
not going to be the player burro or
herbert is at any point in his career
it has become a very harsh reality for
nfl quarterbacks you don't get three
years four years five years and as i've
said many times under today's standards
terry bradshaw would have been back in
shreveport working at walmart nothing
against working i'm just saying he would
have had a normal job just like when tom
brady said i don't want to sell
insurance he would have had a normal job
he would not have been a professional
athlete under today's standards you
don't get that five years to figure out
how to play football because that's the
key to get to the point where you're
comfortable making those decisions
in that moment you need some people need
more reps than others to get to that
point that's right and you got to slow
it down quickly and you got to start
making those decisions quickly and you
got to study and you got to work and you
got to do virtual reality you do all
this stuff that gets you to the point
where you can make those decisions get
rid of the football and uh and
keep it going over and over and over
again
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports